There's nothing quite like a good shock at
the movies.
And while everyone loves to see their heroes
live happily ever after, sometimes audiences
need a reminder that life isn't all sunshine
and roses.
Here are a few movies where the villain actually
wins.
The Star Wars universe is no stranger to a
villainous victory or two, with warring space
factions trading constant blows back and forth
across various conflicts.
Rogue One and Revenge of the Sith certainly
end on some down notes, for example, but the
series' most iconic Dark Side victory came
in the middle chapter of the original trilogy.
Following the first film, which left off on
a Death Star-destroying high, The Empire Strikes
Back came crashing back down to reality when
it opened with the crushing defeat of the
rebel forces on Hoth.
While the movie splinters at that point, with
various characters heading off to do their
own thing, the paths of the protagonists ultimately
lead back to Lando Calrissian's floating haven
of Cloud City.
Unfortunately, when Darth Vader and his minions
show up in Calrissian's city, things quickly
go south for pretty much everyone.
Han Solo is tortured and used as a test subject
for carbon freezing, leaving him in suspended
animation.
Calrissian loses Cloud City to the Empire.
Meanwhile, Luke is lured into a trap and confronted
with one cinema's greatest ever twists.
Needless to say, there's no doubt that Empire's
final act is a home run for Vader and the
Empire from start to finish.
The 2008 film Valkyrie is inspired by the
failed assassination attempt made against
Adolf Hitler in the summer of 1944 by a cabal
of German officers aiming to overthrow the
Nazi regime.
Colonel Claus von Stauffenberg joins Major-General
Henning von Tresckow and a number of other
conspirators, who set up a plan to kill off
the dictator and use the Reserve Army to maintain
order and establish themselves as the new
government.
From there, they plan to use their power to
negotiate favorable peace terms with the Allies,
who at that point are on the clear path to
victory.
The film follows the story just as it actually
unfolded, with everything seeming to move
towards victory for von Stauffenberg and his
co-conspirators.
In fact, the movie does it so well it almost
makes you forget that you already know what's
about to go down.
But alas, Valkyrie is ruthlessly tethered
to reality.
Initially, the assassination comes tantalizingly
close to success, with the planted explosives
going off successfully and Operation Valkyrie
being put into action.
But before long, reports surface that Hitler
survived the explosion, and from there the
whole plot collapses.
The movie ends with Hitler still alive and
the film's heroes executed for treason, which
is about as bad as things possibly could have
gone.
Over the years, Marvel comics have seen plenty
of tragic endings and grisly cliffhangers,
but the MCU itself has tended to prefer the
good guys to come out on top.
But this trend has recently begun to change,
having kicked off in earnest when Captain
America: Civil War pitted the Avengers against
one another, leaving a host of angry, PTSD-ridden
superheroes behind in the process.
This slide downhill only sped up with Thor:
Ragnarok, an otherwise fun movie that ended
with Asgard destroyed and a small handful
of survivors setting out in search of a new
home.
But it was only during Avengers: Infinity
War that Marvel finally opened up a universe
in which the villains really can win.
This colossal crossover event finds the heroes
struggling to rise up and defend the universe
against Thanos and his cronies, only for the
Mad Titan to finally pull off his cataclysmic
finger snap and wipe out half the universe
in the process.
"I am inevitable."
While much of Thanos' mad destruction was
undone in Avengers: Endgame, Infinity War
was nonetheless so focused on Thanos and his
story that his victory during the film's closing
moments was never anything but inevitable.
Se7en follows detectives William Somerset
and David Mills as they investigate a series
of murders by a mysterious criminal who uses
the seven deadly sins as his calling card.
The movie gains speed as the duo uncover the
first five sins, but before the last two take
place, the murderer, known as John Doe, turns
himself in to the authorities while covered
in the blood of an unknown victim.
As the movie wraps up, the growing sense of
impending doom becomes practically unbearable.
Doe directs Mills and Somerset to the desert,
where he informs them that the last two victims
will be found.
Of course, they're already present, as Doe
confesses to being envious of Mills' idyllic
life with his pregnant wife Tracy before a
box arrives on the scene, containing Tracy's
head inside.
Mills then gives in to temptation and kills
Doe, who becomes the final victim of wrath.
Aside from being messed up in so many ways,
Se7en's plot is never in the hands of the
movie's protagonists, with Doe in total control
right up until the credits roll.
Christopher Nolan's The Dark Knight delivered
more than just an outstanding performance
from a greatly-missed actor since Heath Ledger's
Joker was also one of the first superhero
villains to have his way with the hero from
beginning to end.
From the moment he enters that dramatic opening
heist sequence to his last laugh during the
film's climax, the infamous DC villain easily
steals the show.
The Dark Knight revolves almost entirely around
the Joker's schemes against Gotham and Batman
many of which are pulled off without a hitch.
As a result, this second film in Nolan's epic
trilogy leaves Rachel Dawes dead, Harvey Dent
warped into Two-Face and killed soon after,
Batman on the run after taking responsibility
for Dent's crimes, and the Bat-signal destroyed
by Commissioner Gordon.
"See madness, as you know is like gravity.
All it takes is a little push."
And sure, the Joker is eventually apprehended
and has his nihilistic philosophy thoroughly
disproven by the people of Gotham at the same
time — but everything else went off about
as well as he could have hoped.
Christopher Nolan appears to have something
of a gift for letting the villains win.
In this case, you've got Memento.
The narrative follows Leonard Shelby, a man
who suffers from memory loss every five minutes.
This is a recent affliction that has been
occurring ever since two men assaulted and
murdered his wife.
After Shelby killed one of them, the other
knocked him on the head and escaped, leaving
him with his new mental handicap.
Shelby is dead-set on hunting down the other
man responsible for his wife's death, but
plagued with short-term memory loss, he is
forced to use tattoos and Polaroid cameras
in an elaborate system to remind himself of
what he discovers.
The movie is filmed in both color and black-and-white
sequences, showing different angles of perception
and giving a sense of bizarre confusion that
helps the audience relate to the film's hero…
except Shelby isn't the hero.
As the movie concludes, we find that he has
been cyclically hunting down and taking "vengeance"
on innocent people for a year.
Repressing this information, Shelby tampers
with his own photographic evidence, allowing
his condition to wash all guilt away within
the next few minutes and permitting him to
continue his villainous behavior.
While Peter Jackson's film adaptation of J.R.R.
Tolkien's awe-inspiring Lord of the Rings
trilogy has many happy moments during its
runtime, the ending of the first film, The
Fellowship of the Ring, isn't one of them.
As the film reaches its crescendo, the Fellowship
has already gone through the devastating loss
of Gandalf, but things go from bad to worse
as the forces of Mordor close in on them.
Boromir kicks things off by falling to the
lure of the ring and attempting to take it
from Frodo.
Unsuccessful and repentant, Boromir and the
rest of the heroes turn their attention to
a sudden attack of Uruk-Hai soldiers sent
by Saruman to find the Ring.
The attack splits the group up, with the villains
killing Boromir and successfully carrying
off the hobbits Merry and Pippin.
Frodo, meanwhile, leaves with Sam across the
river, and the two begin to work their way
towards Mordor alone.
All in all, this ending is about as chaotic
as it gets and doesn't lead to any one of
the protagonists actually getting their way.
Though triumph lies ahead, the truth is that
Fellowship is a movie about the power of camaraderie
that nonetheless tears its characters away
from each other during its final moments.
And that's about as bleak as it gets.
Though it's outside the canon of the MCU and
doesn't have quite as catastrophic an ending
as Infinity War, X-Men: First Class is another
Marvel movie that doesn't reward its heroes
with a happy ending.
In this prequel to the original X-Men movies,
the storyline jumps back in time to the 1960s
to explore the origin stories of its heroes
and villains.
In particular, the film focuses on the development
of the relationship between Professor Charles
Xavier and Erik Lehnsherr, which is the story
of a profound and meaningful friendship…
right up until it isn't.
"We have it in us to be better men.”
“We already are.
We are the next stage of human evolution you
said it yourself."
While the movie itself brought a fresh spin
to a flagging franchise, its story ended on
a dark note, with the rise of an iconic Marvel
villain: Magneto.
As the film enters its final act, the differences
between Xavier's and Lehnsherr's views on
mutant activism come to a head, with Lehnsherr
dramatically parting ways with the critically-wounded
Xavier and his team.
This sets him on his journey towards becoming
the franchise's most notable villain, and
begins a rivalry fated to go down in history.
Like Valkyrie, Life is Beautiful is another
story that ends with the Nazis coming out
on top.
This classic Italian film was directed and
co-written by the incredibly talented Roberto
Benigni, who also played the lead role alongside
Nicoletta Braschi, his wife of nearly thirty
years.
The first half of the film is almost entirely
light and comedic as it follows Guido, a Jewish
bookshop owner in Italy who shamelessly pursues
the love of his life with a little slapstick
clowning and a lot of Italian charm.
But things take a drastic turn when the narrative
jumps forward several years to a Nazi-occupied
Italy, where Guido, his wife, and their son
are sent to a concentration camp.
Once in the camp, the bookshop owner uses
his incredibly resilient imagination to tirelessly
shield his son from the horrors around them,
convincing the young boy that they're on a
strange kind of holiday.
Despite the subject matter, the movie does
actually build toward a happy ending… until,
in a gut-wrenching turn, Guido is gunned down
by Nazis just as the camp is liberated.
And while Guido's son's innocence is preserved,
the loss of the film's lovable protagonist
is nonetheless a shocking note for the film
to end on.
Just like the classic 1949 George Orwell novel
on which it's based, the movie 1984 is about
as depressing as it gets.
From the infamous "Thought Police" to the
near-endless torture, brainwashing, and "doublethink,"
this movie pretty much established all the
classic tropes of futuristic, dystopian horror.
The film is set in a world where the single,
united super-state of "Oceania" is run like
a well-oiled autocratic machine, in which
every move and thought of its inhabitants
is scrutinized for any deviation from government-approved
behavior.
The story follows Winston Smith, a supposedly
loyal worker at the Ministry of Truth.
Smith "deviates" from the rules when he meets
Julia and begins to secretly pursue an affair
with the daring fellow thought-criminal.
Of course, government forces prove much more
powerful than two people, and the end of the
movie shows the couple as they're caught and
put through a system of "rehabilitation,"
in which they are tortured and forced to face
their greatest fears in order to break their
rebellion and ensure their future cooperation
with the regime.
And that heart-breaking ending in the cafe,
in which Julia and Winston coldly admit they
betrayed each other, leaves no doubt whatsoever
that Big Brother has come out on top.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
movies are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.